how is it we should measure information
in a way that applies to any
communication system you can think of
human animal or alien
well let's return to the late 19th
century where at the time we were
focused as we are today on speed and one
goal to improve speed was to design a
machine which allowed the operators to
input letters which we could think of as
primary symbols and have the machine
automate the lower-level signaling
events such as pulses of electricity
what we can call secondary symbols and
machines can be driven by some clock
source allowing it to generate a precise
and rapid pulse stream which presumably
would run much faster than any human
hand and one great example of this was
the Bedok multiplex system and the
design was put into service in 1874 and
it built off the same conceptual ideas
we've seen in the shuttered Telegraph it
consisted of five keys which could be
played in any combination think of it as
a cord each combination would represent
a unique message with five notes each
either on or off
you can play 2 to the power of 5 or 32
different cords the code assigned the 32
different cords to each letter of the
alphabet with the left over used for
carriage returns newline and spaces so
the operator would literally play
letters and their machine would
automatically output a pulse stream
representing the letters
like this for letter T or like this for
letter R or like this for letter B so we
have an output signal containing various
combinations of DC impulses a signal
that accurately represents the message
typed on the teletypewriter behind the
counter the mechanical nerves of the
system change words two holes on tape
and the holes on tape two electrical
impulses speeding over the wires notice
at the lowest level this system is
exchanging either the presence or
absence of electrical current in a
sequence divided using a clock so how
fast can our internal clocks run well
the limiting speed was not the clock
then and today the speed of transmission
was physically limited by the minimum
spaces between these impulses or the
pulse rate and this problem plagued
engineers who were testing underground
submarine cables using the existing
Morse code system and it's similar to an
echo or a sustained note if one sends
dots too fast over a long undersea
circuit they will run together at the
receiving end because the symbol we
received at the far end of the circuit
will be a slightly longer smoothed out
rise and fall not an exact replica and
sending pulses too fast
results in inter symbol interference
this occurs for example when the longer
flow of a current bleeds into the next
time division and perhaps reverses a 0
to a 1 so even if we are automating the
detection of these current levels there
is a fundamental limit to how far we can
squeeze two pulses together and this is
the same problem Alice and Bob ran into
with their string communication system
which we called the maximum pluck speed
if they plucked any faster than - plucks
per second they noticed they started to
bleed together and they got confused so
this is called the symbol rate remember
a symbol can be broadly defined as the
current state of some observable signal
which persists for a fixed period of
time whether you are using fire sound
electrical current anything a signaling
event is simply a change from one state
to another so the symbol rate is the
number of signaling events which can be
squeezed together in one second it also
became clear that there was one other
way to increase the capacity of a
communication system we can increase the
number of different signaling events for
example with Alice and Bob's string
communication system they soon found
that varying the type of plucks allowed
them to send their messages faster for
example hard medium versus soft plucks
or high pitch versus low pitch plucks by
tightening the cable different amounts
and this was an idea implemented by
Thomas Edison which he applied to the
Morse code system and it was based on
the idea that you could use weak and
strong batteries to produce signals of
different strengths he also used two
directions as Gauss and Weber did
forward versus reverse current and two
intensities so he had plus three volts
plus one volt minus 1 volt and minus 3
volt for different current values which
could be exchanged it enabled Western
Union to save money by greatly
increasing the number of messages the
company could send without building new
lines
and this is known as the quadruplex
Telegraph and it continued to be used
into the 20th century but again as we
expanded the number of different
signaling events we ran into another
problem for example why not send a
thousand or a million different voltage
levels per pulse well as you may expect
fine-grain differences lead to
difficulties on the receiving end and
with electrical systems the resolution
of these differences is always limited
by electrical noise if we attach a probe
to any electrical line and zoom in
closely enough we will always find minut
undesired currents and this is an
unavoidable result of natural processes
such as heat or geomagnetic storms and
even latent effects of the Big Bang so
the differences between signaling events
must be great enough that noise cannot
randomly bump a signaling event from one
type to another clearly now we can step
back and begin to define the capacity of
a communication system using these two
very simple ideas first how many symbol
transfers per second which we called
symbol rate and today it's known simply
as bod for a meal bod oh and we can
define this as n where it's n symbol
transfers per second and number two how
many differences per symbol which we can
think of as the symbol space
how many symbols can we select from at
each point and we can call this s and as
we've seen before these parameters can
be thought of as a decision tree of
possibilities because each symbol can be
thought of as a decision where the
number of branches depend on the number
of differences and after n symbols we
have a tree with s to the power of n
leaves and since each path
through this tree can represent a
message we can think of the number of
leaves as the size of the message space
and this is easy to visualize the
message space is simply the width of the
base of one of these trees and it
defines the total number of possible
messages one could send given a sequence
of n symbols for example let's say Alice
sends Bob a message which consists of
two plucks and they are using a hard
versus soft pluck as their communication
system this means she has the ability to
define one of four possible messages to
Bob and if instead they were using a
system of hard versus medium versus soft
plucks then with - plucks she has the
ability to define one of three to the
power of two equals nine messages and
with three plucks this jumps to one of
twenty seven messages now if instead
Alice and Bob were exchanging written
notes in class which contain only two
letters on a piece of paper then a
single note would contain one of 26 to
the power of two or 676 possible
messages
it's important to realize now that we no
longer care about the meaning applied to
these chains of differences merely how
many different messages are possible the
resulting sequences could represent
numbers names feelings music or perhaps
even some alien alphabet we could never
understand when we look at a
communication system now we can begin to
think about its capacity as how many
different things you could say and we
could then use the message space to
define exactly how many differences are
possible in any situation and this
simple yet elegant idea forms the basis
for how information will be later
defined and this is the final step that
brings us to modern information theory
and it emerges in the early 20th century
you